As you can see, we're getting pretty close to our mock up,
but the page looks a little bland.
Of course, we don't have the right colors over here, and
it also looks like the text isn't formatted quite the same either.
Notice how in the mock up we're right aligned, but
over here on our site right now we are on the left.
Also notice how this name and
title are both in all caps, while ours are capitalized normally.
Check out Bootstrap's documentation to see if there are any classes that'll help
you easily fix things like alignment and capitalization.
I recommend checking out the Typography section.
This is a two-part question.
In the first part,
pick the classes that you need to right-align text and make text all uppercase.
For the second part of this question,
which of these elements need the classes that you've defined up here?
Div class equal row, div class equals column medium six,
or is it the h1 header and h3 header?
Check all that apply